yeah gone versus tuivasa is i mean it's
interesting on so many different levels
because you've got the stylistic matchup
you've got gone who is one of the more
technical strikers in the entire
division really does not move like a
heavy weight i mean he's one of the few
heavyweights who genuinely doesn't move
like a heavyweight and then you've got
to ivassa who super fast but he's got
more of that traditional heavy hands i'm
going to go out there i'm going to bang
it up but he started to incorporate more
of his wrestling so i mean i love this
fight for so many reasons the stylistic
matchup is one of them but then just
having
both of these guys young in this
division heavyweights heating up again
you got tom asmull i know he's out with
an injury but as soon as he gets back
you've got the the specter of jon jones
kind of hanging in the wings
we'll see when and if he comes back
we're thinking maybe it's going to be a
december november time period so
heavyweight heavyweight is heating up
for sure but i think gone versus tuivasa
obviously super important fight for that
division